swine dirty talk a motherly girlfriend
in more ways than one unwelcome visitors
and selfies these moments in Frasier
will make you say yikes
I can throw you down on this floor right
now and hi
a little over halfway through the final
season of Frasier Lori Metcalf becomes
the third actress to play in the net
Guzman Frazier's ex-wife with whom he
shares a potent sexual chemistry Nanette
is best known as the popular children's
TV and Stage personality Nanny G and
when she shows up in caught in the act
Roz forces a reunion between her and
Frasier in hopes of scoring tickets to
Nanette's performance for her daughter
then that is desperate for a trust with
Frasier but we soon learned she's
remarried
love here does well just about
everything for me he's my he's manager
producer so writer publicist husband I
was getting there on the night of her
nanny G Performance Frazier goes
backstage to tell her nothing can happen
between them Nanette manages to seduce
Frasier regardless and they throw each
other on a bed and begin to take things
too far when the bed begins lifting off
the ground it turns out this is the
opening of Nanny G's show when she's
supposed to emerge from the bed to sing
the first number at first Frazier buck
naked at this point hides under the
covers while Nanette sings desperately
she shoves a costume under the blankets
that includes a baby Bonnet and a diaper
Frasier emerges from the bed wearing the
ridiculous and disturbing outfit and
Nanny G announces in surprise that she
has a new baby brother Frazier tries to
dance his way off the stage only to find
Nanette's angry husband waiting for him
in the wings
the season 7 premiere Mamma Mia
introduces us to a new love interest and
at first Frazier is blind to the reason
of her Allure while waiting for a blind
date at Cafe nervosa Frazier is smitten
with woman we soon learn is children's
author Marie Preston played by Rita
Wilson in spite of an awkward and funny
mix up at the coffee shop Frasier and
Mia hit it off there's no immediately
apparent reason to feel at all strange
about the pairing until Mia meets Niles
who reveals to Daphne that Frasier's new
girlfriend is the spitting image of
their dead mother does she remind you of
anyone oh you noticed that too are you
kidding from the minute I laid eyes on
it even I can see it when Mia joins the
family for a weekend in a cottage Marty
agrees with Niles's observation and it
makes things even weirder when Mia acts
motherly toward Frazier like offering to
cut up his food for him Marty and Niles
argue about whether or not to say
something to Frazier but when they watch
a home movie that includes Frasier's
actual mom and he sees the resemblance
for himself they don't need to
unfortunately once Frazier sees the
similarities it ends things between him
and Mia but it isn't the end of Rita
Wilson's time on Frasier Wilson reprises
the role of Frasier's actual mother as
part of a dream sequence in season 9's
Don Juan In Hell part two
Frazier isn't known for an affinity for
physical labor and in season 10's some
assembly required we discover an
interesting and disturbing reason why he
should probably stay away from such
Endeavors Frazier's co-workers at the
station sign him up for a program that
builds houses for low-income families
when the house is complete Frazier makes
a speech as if he were singularly
responsible for the entire House's
construction however his anecdotes
reveal he was only allowed to perform
the most limited of tasks like stirring
paint regardless Frazier develops a
strange attachment to the house and its
new family he visits them just after
they move in and offers some
pre-decorating tips
Fisher hi what a surprise honey guess
who's here again the family is grateful
at first but their gratitude grows sour
as Frasier not only won't stop dropping
in Uninvited but continues to criticize
their decorating choices he gives them
tons of unasked for accessories and acts
betrayed when he discovers they've put
up a cow-shaped mailbox rather than the
one he bought them as a gift the new
homeowners are forced to eventually
shove him out their front door so that
he'll get the message he does eventually
come to his senses and apologize and
they reward him with a tour of their
fully decorated home Frasier is barely
able to contain shrieks of horror when
he discovers the new black and white cow
theme of the Interior along with a
freshly painted bathroom that Frasier
describes with wow that's purple
in the final season of Frasier Julia
Sweeney guest stars as n an insurance
claims adjuster that Roz sets up with
Frasier in the placeholder Roz knows
things won't work out between Anne and
Frazier but she acts as Matchmaker
anyway to keep Frasier's dating skills
from wasting away Frazier wants no part
of it at first but after an awkward
night of being the fifth wheel at
couples dinner and another night of cat
sitting that makes him feel like an old
maid he's willing to take the plunge
along with just the cringy notion of
dating someone as a placeholder
Frasier's treatment event doesn't make
him appear to be much of a gentleman
he's really annoyed by Anne right away
and isn't looking forward to the rest of
the evening when Anne heads to the
restroom Frazier's co-worker Kenny shows
up with his lovely cousin Liz Wright
making her literally Miss Right Frazier
lies to them saying his dinner with Anne
is just business and he spends the rest
of the day trying to ditch and so he can
take a shot with Liz of course both Anne
and Liz eventually figure out what
Frasier's up to and he gets the public
shaming he deserves though absurdly and
still wants to meet him for coffee the
next morning you're right I don't know
what to say
well maybe you can come up with
something before we have coffee tomorrow
Frazier uses the line on listening when
he takes calls on his radio show this
episode from season 11 uses the line for
its title and sees the good doctor
eavesdrop at all the wrong times
I don't know why you're always saying
I'm listening because you always are
early in the episode he accidentally
overhears Wendy Malik's Ronnie Marty's
new love interest making a date with
another man on the phone later he winds
up hiding in the kitchen when Marty
confronts Ronnie about the date but
without a doubt the most cringy snooping
comes at the end of the episode Frazier
is searching Ronnie's car for a lost
money clip when she and Marty show up
appearing to be on the brink of breaking
up Frasier hides in the back seat and
listens to the makeup and eventually
agree to date each other exclusively for
a second it looks like Frazier will get
a chance to escape when the couple
starts to head upstairs but then Ronnie
has a better idea about driving to a
secluded beach so she and Marty can
steam up the windows Frazier throws
himself down on the back seat before
either of them can spot him and we can
only assume unwillingly goes along for
the ride where he's likely forced to
know much more about his father's love
life than he ever wanted to
as the show reaches its final season
it's only natural for ideas to run dry
such is the case with Frasier season 11.
in episode 17 Coots and ladders Frasier
recounts his bad day in a series of
flashbacks while Niles anticipates a
crime Frazier has admitted to committing
although it's not exactly the most
entertaining plotline of the series one
moment in particular will make you
cringe after kleptomaniac calls into his
radio show and a beautiful woman turns
down his advances Frazier finds himself
helping his elderly neighbor change her
light bulb when he learns the 83 year
old woman is still successfully dating
Frasier's bitterness comes to a boiling
point and he Pockets one of the woman's
trinkets Frazier's over-the-top reaction
is played for Laughs as he and Niles try
to return the item but it's not as funny
when you remember he's a grown educated
man taking advantage of a trusting Elder
the cringiest part of all arrives when
Frasier and Niles stumble into the
woman's surprise birthday party and have
to talk their way out of Frasier's step
they go through many hoops trying to
return the item without anyone noticing
thankfully they succeed but we're left
cringing at the two foolish crane
Brothers
Frazier has a chaotic dating life the
snooty middle-aged psychiatrist can't
seem to hold down a woman for the life
of him although he doesn't have much
luck with the ladies he still has not
given up hope but sometimes that doesn't
feel like a virtue many of Frasier's
most cringe-worthy moments are the
result of him trying to impress women
we'll give him an a for his mostly
respectful effort but we won't forgive
the cringy dirty talk between him and
his new girlfriend Madeline in season
two's adventures in Paradise part 1
Frazier and Madeline take a romantic
trip to Bora Bora he soon finds out that
they've booked a room next to his
ex-wife and her new lover which is awful
enough on its own but surprisingly it
doesn't come close to the moment the
couple hops in bed together and indulges
in the worst kind of foreplay Frasier
exclaims I'm sweating like the pig that
knows he's dinner when Madeline leaves
to freshen up Frasier makes everything
worse I'll be right back
oink Madeleine might be into the strange
Pig reference but for everyone else it's
become a suppressed nightmare
we love the crane Brothers for their
intellectual interests and expensive
tastes when they're not putting others
down because of them anyway but when the
two get tickets to see the hottest play
in town their excitement quickly Fades
after they realize the tickets were for
an earlier time forcing them to scrounge
at the last minute they'll do whatever
it takes to maintain their high-class
social standing except wait in the
cancellation line like a couple of
peasants
best thing I need is to have someone see
us loitering outside here like gutter
Riff Raff pathetically scrounging for
last minute tickets their superiority
complexes are often Charming but in this
case they lean towards cringe it's
uncomfortable to watch Frasier and Niles
desperately try to conceal their lack of
prestige everyone wants to impress their
friends every once in a while but it's
in the crane Brothers nature to take
things too far in reality it's likely
their friends and the rest of high
society couldn't care less about Frasier
and Niles ticket status
Frasier and Niles don't have the best
relationship with their father Martin
their combative Dynamic is first
introduced in the pilot episode when
Frazier agrees to let his injured father
move in with him although they learn to
make it work their distinctly
oppositional personalities constantly
Clash this remains true in season one's
dinner at eight after trying to take
Martin to a fancy restaurant that's
obviously out of his comfort zone Martin
treats his boys to his own favorite
restaurant Fraser and Niles can't help
but rag on the place for its lower class
status their outright offended by the
Casual wait staff and steak and potato
offerings despite Martin's attempts to
Humble his sons they don't let up on
their not so subtle insults Martin is
forced to leave the situation instead of
apologizing Frasier and Niles make it
their mission to finish their food in
their father's honor they even go as far
as staying after closing forcing the
wait staff to wait for them to finish
the food they clearly despise the entire
Affair is enough to make anyone cringe
oh Daphne it was only a matter of time
before you made Frasier fans cringe
throughout the show Niles and Daphne
experience say well they won't they
relationship with Daphne oblivious to
Niles's true feelings they finally make
things official at the end of season 8
which leads to season 9's the first
temptation of Daphne still new in their
relationship Daphne feels a tinge of
jealousy and uncertainty when Nas's new
patient is revealed to have a crush on
it instead of trusting Niles to treat
this patient she goes behind his back
and looks through the patient's
confidential medical file not only is it
cringe-inducing to witness her
insecurities and lack of boundaries it's
genuinely shocking what Daphne does is a
crime we can't even say that she learns
her lesson because after coming clean
she faces no consequences for her
actions instead she and Niall's makeup
and the patient is left exploited
a young Zooey Deschanel guest stars as
Roz's wild and opinionated cousin Jen in
season 10's kissing cousin she embodies
the cynical 20-something with just the
right amount of cringe and attitude Jen
isn't afraid to speak her mind even when
it comes to disagreeing with Frasier
about his beloved Freud listening to her
go off on tangents about how everyone
and everything is inferior to her unique
tastes is intensely cringy even Roz gets
sick of her constant partying and
tendency to put her down for getting old
everyone feels alienated by Jen's
Behavior except for a certain station
manager Kenny feels inspired by Jen's
spontaneous and carefree view of the
world it's sweet to see Kenny gain
confidence from Jen's words but watching
them partake in a makeout session is
significantly less so clearly this is
where the episode gets its title from
overall it probably would be better off
without the creepy gag so Seattle still
loves the one man huh
Frasier's AM radio show is one of his
greatest successes he feels good about
himself when he helps to the people of
Seattle with their problems and is
constantly recognized for his stardom
he's put up on such a high pedestal in
fact that when a stranger from the radio
station's focus group gives his show
negative feedback in season three's the
focus group Frazier goes out of his way
to harass the innocent Manu is a new
standard who does nothing more than
Express his opinion when asked for it he
simply States
I don't like it it's a fair assessment
but Frazier gets fixated on it he goes
out of his way to track down Manu to
better understand why he said what he
said Manu is a good guy and he feels
betrayed by the radio station for lying
to him about the hosts listening in the
last thing he wants to do is talk poorly
about someone else in his search for
answers Frasier ends up burning down
manu's newsstand and livelihood this
lack of empathy and narcissistic
behavior makes for a seriously
cringe-worthy scene
in the season 5 premiere Frasier's
imaginary friend the titular lead hits
it off with supermodel Kelly Easterbrook
on a plane trip to Mexico during their
romantic weekend Kelly tells him she is
in the middle of a breakup with a
professional football player and asks
him to be discreet back home Frasier
unintentionally convinces his family and
co-workers that he's gone from being
lonely to delusional when he confides in
his father brother and Daphne who is
dating they think he's lying to avoid
humiliation it gets to the point where
his family pays a surprise visit to him
in a restaurant where he says he's
meeting Kelly and because she has to
leave the dinner early for an emergency
Niles and Marty find Frasier eating
alone and are more convinced than ever
that Kelly is as real as Santa Claus
rather than simply telling Kelly about
the situation and asking if he could
take a picture of them to offer his
proof work better yet just let the whole
thing go Frasier goes down a
disturbingly creepy path one night
Frasier Waits until Kelly is sound
asleep pulls the sheets down to reveal
her shoulder and tries to take a selfie
years before anyone used the word
predictably Kelly wakes up and once she
realizes what Frasier's trying to do she
tells him exactly what she thinks of
what he's done considering his behavior
it's tough to blame her for dumping him
hard
in season three's the friend Frasier is
disappointed to realize he's spent a few
years back in his hometown without
forging any new friendships against
Roz's advice he uses his radio show to
look for new buddies and as his producer
predicts most of the people who respond
are cringier than the show's cringiest
episodes but amid all the refuse there
appears to be a possible gem Bob
Reynolds who sends Frazier a very sane
friendly facts Frasier meets Bob for
coffee and at first things are going
well Frazier and Bob played by Griffin
Dunn share a love of literature but
that's about as far as their
similarities go along with revealing an
annoying tendency to use air quotes
often and without any Rhyme or Reason
Bob spends the rest of the Meetup Lauren
Frazier by talking about his obsession
with barbecue Frazier is about to tell
Bob he'd rather not share dinner with
him when Bob backs up from the table
revealing he's in a wheelchair Frazier
eventually breaks things off after first
telling Bob truth but when Bob says he
wishes it was the wheelchair that turned
Frazier off because that would make
Frasier The Jerk instead of Bob the
psychiatrist lies and says the chair is
the problem which Bob uses to turn all
the employees and patrons of Cafe
nervosa against him
[Music]
foreign